Доброго дня!
Вітаю вас на уроці цариці
наук математики в 11 класі.
Мене
звати Дмитро Номіровський.
Батькам, здається, за мене не було
соромно. Хіба що там - декілька разів.
Щось там в голові є.
Сьогодні ми поговоримо про тіла обертання.
З нами сьогодні в класі
працюють наші зіркові гості.
Давайте їх спитаємо, чи знають
вони, що таке тіло обертання?
Я довірю цю відповідь Гарику.
Давайте послухаємо. Я
знаю, що таке конус і циліндр.
А тіло обертання, ну, напевно, що те
тіло, яке обертається навколо своєї осі.
Чудово! Бачите, от майже вичерпна
відповідь але подивимось,
що нам каже з цього приводу наш
інформаційний партнер сайт Wikipedia.
Давайте подумаємо, де ми бачимо
тіла обертання в нашому житті.
От давайте спитаємо наших
учнів. Де ми бачимо тіла обертання?
Тепер Костя, давай я тобі … А у мікрохвильовій пічці.
А що, там тіло …?
А, там теж щось обертається. Там
є диск. Да, непоганий приклад. Ще?
- Глобус.
- Класний приклад. Планета наша Земля.
- Да, да, класні приклади. Я наведу ще декілька.
Ось, наприклад, коли майстер
з обробки деревини чи металу
працює з матеріалом, то він,
власне, працює з тілом обертання
– обертається вал і ми бачимо
тіло обертання, яке утворюється.
Ось бачимо чудові деталі. Крім цього,
параболічна антена – це
теж приклад тіла обертання.
Повітряна куля, теж бачимо,
що це – тіло обертання.
Сьогодні ми поговоримо про найпростіші
тіла обертання конус і циліндр.
Почнемо з конусу. Знов таки, давайте
пригадаємо, які конуси чи конічні поверхні
оточують нас в нашому житті? От, знов
таки, давайте послухаємо можливі
відповіді. Де ми бачимо конуси?
Шапочка на день народження.
О, чудово, да – шапочка
на день народження. Ще?
- Колони.
- Колони, конічні колони? Вони, мабуть,
циліндричні, все ж
таки? Чи бувають конічні?
Тут ви мене спіймали, отримую
двійку. Конічні. Нам треба конічні, да.
Ну, ялинка. Ялинка, класно, да.
- Піраміди. Ні, це теж не конуси?
- Я не почув.
- Піраміди.
- Піраміди?
Ні, нам треба, щоб воно
оберталося. От як би …
А ялинка обертається. Якщо вона штучна,
наприклад. Ялинка не обертається,
але вона має отакий …
- Морозиво, може бути.
- Морозиво, от бачите,
вгадують приклади,
які я заготував.
Перший приклад – це гори. Ось
гора має вигляд конуса.
І морозиво. Бачимо чудове
морозиво – конус. Ще які приклади?
Шляпа, головний убор. Ну, можемо
згадати розподільний капелюх Гарі Поттера,
який визначив, що Гарі Поттер
іде до Ґріфіндора, а не до Слизеріну.
От зараз ми бачимо ще конуси – це дорожні
конуси, які організують рух на дорозі.
Так, ну а тепер перейдемо
до нашої віртуальної студії,
до проекту www.besmart.study
і подивимося: як визначається конус,
які він має властивості
і які він має елементи.
Наступна стереометрична
фігура, яку ми розглянемо
на цьому уроці – це конус.
Подивимося на нього.
Конус.
Конус – фігура, подібна
до піраміди. Єдина
відмінність, що в основі
конуса лежить не многокутник,
а коло. Ось коло з радіусом R.
Деяка вершина – це вершина
конуса. Ця вершина з’єднується з усіма
точками цього кола. Утворюється
поверхня, яку називають конусом.
Оця лінія, яка з’єднує вершину
конуса з будь-якою точкою на колі.
Оцю лінію, цей відрізок називають
твірною. Це один з головних елементів
конуса. Радіус основи. В основі –
коло, радіус R. Ну, ще й висота конуса
теж інколи грає важливу роль – це
відстань від вершини до центра основи.
Сформулюємо основні властивості конуса.
Площа бічної поверхні конуса обчислюється
за ось такою формулою, яку ви бачите
на слайді. Площа бічної поверхні Пі*R*L.
R – це радіус основи, L – довжина твірної.
І об’єм конуса можна знайти за формулою
– одна третина добутку площі основи на
висоту. Але в основі конуса лежить круг,
тому: площа основи
дорівнює Пі*R-квадрат.
Отже: одна третина, площа
основи на висоту.
Ось такі головні властивості конуса.
Давайте проілюструємо
оцю першу формулу,
розглянувши модель конуса.
Перед нами конус. Давайте
знайдемо формулу для площі поверхні
цього конуса. Ось вершина
конуса, твірна L.
Ось основа конуса радіуса R.
Як же знайти площу поверхні оцієї фігури?
Розріжемо конус по твірній.
Я його розрізаю.
Так. І він розгортається ось
у таку фігуру. Ось був конус.
Розгорнувся ось у таку
фігуру. Зверніть увагу, що всі
твірні конуса – це однакові
відрізки. Отже, оця фігура –
це частина великого круга.
Ель (твірна) – це радіус цього
великого круга. А радіус основи R
дозволяє знайти довжину основи,
довжину кола, яке лежало в основі.
Це коло (ось воно) перетворилося
ось в цю лінію. Таким чином,
нам відомо, що радіус оцього
сектора дорівнює довжині
твірної Ель. І відома довжина оцієї
дуги – вона пов’язана з радіусом
основи цього конуса: 2*Пі*R.
R – це радіус основи, 2*Пі*R – це
довжина цього кола.
Знайдемо площу поверхні конуса. Ось він
перед нами, знайдемо його площу.
Намалюємо поверхню конуса.
Ось це – твірна Ель,
тут також твірна Ель.
А довжина оцієї дуги: 2-Пі-R.
R – це радіус основи конуса.
Знайдемо площу цього сектора.
Якщо розглянути повний круг, ось він,
то його площа (S круга) дорівнює:
Пі*Ель-Квадрат.
Сектор складає лише певну
частину цього круга. Ця частина
визначається довжиною оцієї дуги.
Отже, довжина дуги 2*Пі*R в
стільки разів менша довжини
всього великого кола 2*Пі*Ель
(це довжина всього великого кола,
довжина оцієї лінії), як шукана площа
поверхні конуса відноситься до
площі всього круга –
отже, до величини
Пі*Ель-квадрат. Скорочуємо величини, які
тут є – 2*Пі скоротилося, Ель і одне Ель
скоротилося. Щоб знайти площу поверхні
конуса S треба ліву і праву частини
домножити на Пі*Ель.
Маємо: S конуса дорівнює Пі*Ер*Ель.
Це – шукана формула.
Давайте розглянемо задачу на конус.
Це задача теж з реального тесту ЗНО.
Умову задачі ви бачите на екрані.
Пропонується п’ять варіантів відповідей.
Ну, справді – це дуже проста задача,
оскільки тут треба лише знати формулу
для обчислення площі бічної поверхні.
Ми її тільки що вивели.
Давайте нагадаємо її.
Площа бічної поверхні конуса
дорівнює Пі*Ер*Ель, а, отже – виразимо
з цієї формули радіус через
площу бічної поверхні і твірну Ель.
Маємо: радіус основи
дорівнює S поділити на Пі*Ель.
Обидві частини цієї рівності ділимо
на Пі*Ель. Маємо таку рівність:
радіус дорівнює S поділити на Пі*Ель.
Дивимося – яка з запропонованих формул
відповідає цьому співвідношенню.
Бачимо, що це варіант “Д”.
S на Пі*Ель, ну єдине що твірну
позначили великою літерою Ель
Ми розв’язали цю задачу. Відповідь: “Д”.
Ще один приклад, теж
з реального тесту ЗНО.
Задача: об’єм тіла, утвореного
обертанням рівнобедреного трикутника.
Отже, є рівнобедрений трикутник АВС.
АС – основа. АВ дорівнює ВС.
І цей трикутник обертається
навколо висоти ВО.
Тобто, уявляємо цей трикутник у
просторі, оцей відрізок ВО нерухомий.
Він є віссю обертання і ми обертаємо цей
трикутник навколо цієї вісі.
Треба уявити фігуру
тіла, яке при цьому утворюється.
Ось, це тіло зображено на цьому рисунку.
Бачимо ось цей трикутник. Під час
обертання утвориться конус.
Отже, трикутник АВС
обертається навколо висоти ВО,
при цьому утворюється
тіло – конус.
Відомо, що об’єм цього конуса дорівнює
320*Пі сантиметрів кубічних.
Треба обчислити довжину
бічної сторони початкового
рівнобедреного трикутника,
оцю довжину АВ,
якщо відомо, що
довжина основи цього
рівнобедреного трикутника АС – 16 см.
Отже, нам відомо відрізок АС – він 16 см
і об’єм утвореного тіла
(ми знаємо, що це – конус) –
320*Пі сантиметрів кубічних.
Шукаємо АВ.
Як підійти до розв’язку
цієї задачі?
Оскільки відрізок АС є діаметром
основи цього конуса,
то радіус цього конуса
дорівнює АС поділити на 2.
16 ділимо на 2,
маємо 8 см.
Отже, радіус основи, радіус цього
кола – 8 см.
Позначимо висоту цього конуса h,
нехай ВО буде h і знайдемо
об’єм цього конуса. Виразимо об’єм цього
конуса через радіус і
висоту. Згадуємо формулу:
об’єм конуса дорівнює
одна третина площі основи
на висоту, площа
основи – це Пі*R-квадрат.
R нам відомо – це 8.
Вісім в квадраті – це 64.
64 третіх Пі*h –
ось такий вираз.
І, за умовою задачі, об’єм
конуса дорівнює 320*Пі.
З цієї рівності можна
знайти h. Ділимо на Пі.
Маємо такий вираз.
Ділимо ліву і праву частину
на 32. Тоді тут замість 320*Пі вийде 10.
А тут: 64 поділити на
32 – це буде 2,
множимо на 3, ділимо на 2.
Виходить h=15.
Отже, ми знайшли h – 15 см.
Тепер, якщо нам відома висота
цього конуса (відрізок ВО) –
повернемося на цей малюнок.
Висота
ось вона: ВО=15 см.
І нам відома відстань між
точками А і О – це 8 см.
Отже АВ можна знайти
за теоремою Піфагора.
Знаходимо.
АО – це R в квадраті,
h в квадраті – це відрізок ВО.
Підставляємо значення: R – це 8, h – 15.
Виконуємо множення і додавання,
отримуємо 289. Тут треба згадати таблицю
повних квадратів (на
початку курсу я просив вас
вивчити квадрати
основних чисел, хоча б,
в межах до 30). Корінь із
числа 289 – це 17.
Отже, бічне ребро
початкового рівнобедреного
трикутника – це 17 см.
Ми розв’язали цю задачу.
І більше інформації, тестів
і завдань ви можете знайти
на сайті проекту: www.besmart.study.
А ми рухаємося далі.
Задамо контрольне запитання.
Чому дорівнює об’єм конуса? І
пропонується три варіанти відповідей.
Варіанти відповідей ви бачите на екрані.
S – це площа основи конуса.
h – висота.
Ось давайте подумаємо, пригадаємо що
було у нашій віртуальній студії.
Чому дорівнює об’єм
конуса? Хто зможе відповісти?
S – це площа, h – висота?
Ну, це варіант “В”.
Чудово – це правильна відповідь.
Бачите, ми створюємо майбутніх
математиків нашої країни.
Це справді варіант “В” – Sh/3.
А я запропоную ще одну
ілюстрацію, яка, можливо,
зацікавить батьків, які
теж дивляться наш урок.
Уявіть собі, що ви хочете
дати вашій дитині гірку мікстуру.
Звичайно, дитина не хоче пити
такі ліки. Тоді ви можете схитрувати
і скористатися келихом конічної
форми. Запропонуйте випити половину.
Справа в тому, що
якщо дитина вип’є половину
мікстури за висотою,
то це, насправді, буде
складати майже 90% об’єму.
І, отже, ви досягнете своєї мети.
Цікаво й те, що це правило
працює й у зворотній бік.
Тож, якщо, шановні батьки, вам
колись буде необхідно обґрунтувати
своє бажання випити більше,
теж погоджуйтесь на половину.
У якості домашнього
завдання, я вам пропоную
обґрунтувати ці два факти.
Перший факт: порахувати
справжню кількість рідини,
яку вип’є дитина,
якщо об’єм рідини зменшиться
по висоті до половини.
І друге питання.
Порахуйте, будь ласка,
на скільки має опуститися
рівень рідини для того, щоб
дитина випила саме половину мікстури.
І ви побачите,
що це не така значна частина цієї висоти.
А ми перейдемо
до наступного тіла обертання – циліндра.
Давайте спробуємо пригадати,
де ми бачимо циліндри в нашому житті.
Ось нам вже нагадували,
що це – циліндричні колони. Що ще?
Є в нас циліндри?
Ну, якщо монетки викласти
вверх, то це буде циліндр.
Це – да, класно, бо гроші – це
актуальна проблема.
Якби ми в XIX столітті жили, то в нас
би були циліндри-капелюхи.
О, циліндри-капелюхи. Так.
Ну, в автомобілі в нас є
циліндри, які іпо формі, і по якості …
Бачите, ми всі з’ясували, що
циліндри нас оточують майже всюди.
І ще декілька прикладів від мене.
Бочки і ємності
– це найрізноманітніші циліндри.
Ось ще одна ємність – це банка.
Далі, труби – це найтиповіші циліндри.
Ось газотранспортна система України
складається з таких великих труб великого
діаметру і їх треба розраховувати.
В оточуючому середовищі,
в природі ми бачимо
щось схоже на циліндр
– це стовбури дерев.
Ще цистерни.
Звісно – цистерни, ємкості.
Рулони – це циліндри.
Вони нагадують циліндр.
І, звісно, торт. Торт –
це теж приклад циліндру.
А бублик – приклад циліндру?
Дуже класне питання.
Бублик – це не циліндр,
це – тіло, яке теж є
тілом обертання, бо
обертається навколо вісі.
І воно має спеціальну назву
математичну. Називається – тором.
Це тіло не вивчається в середній
школі, тому запрошую на математичні
факультети і там ми попрацюємо
з тороми більш детально.
Так, а ми рухаємося далі. І, знов таки,
перейдемо до нашої віртуальної студії.
Проект besmart. І вивчимо деталі і
елементи циліндрів та їх властивості.
Перейдемо до іншого
стереометричного тіла – циліндр.
Циліндр
Циліндр складається з двох
кругів. Вони лежать в основах.
Отже, циліндр відрізняється
від призми тим, що в основах
лежать круги, а не n-кутники.
З’єднаємо кожну точку
відповідну цих кругів з
відповідною точкою іншої основи.
Утворюються от такі лінії, які
в цілому складають поверхню
цього циліндра. Якщо ми
з’єднаємо відповідні точки,
то оцей відрізок називають твірною
циліндра. Відстань від центра
круга до точки на колі – це
радіус. Отже, радіус і твірна
– це основні елементи циліндра.
Властивості циліндра.
Площу бічної поверхні циліндра
можна знайти за формулою
2Пі*R*h (формула на
екрані). Об’єм циліндра дорівнює
добутку площі основи
циліндра на висоту
(формулу ви бачите на екрані).
Але в основі циліндра лежить круг,
тобто, його площа дорівнює
Пі*R квадрат, множимо на висоту –
і це об’єм циліндра. Зверніть
увагу, що оця формула точно
відповідає формулі об’єму
призми – площа основи на висоту.
Давайте обґрунтуємо, як
можна отримати цю формулу.
Для цього розглянемо модель циліндра.
Перед нами циліндр. Ось
твірна цього циліндра.
В основі у нас круг радіуса
R. Давайте знайдемо площу
поверхні цього циліндра.
Розріжемо циліндр за твірною.
Ось я беру цей
циліндр і розрізаю за твірною.
При цьому, циліндр перетворюється в
ось такий прямокутник. Твірна – це одна зі
сторін цього прямокутника. А інша сторона
по довжині дорівнює довжині кола,
що лежало в основі. Ось це коло і воно
розгорнулося в сторону цього прямокутника.
Знайдемо площу цього прямокутника, вона
буде дорівнювати площі поверхні циліндра.
Намалюємо цей прямокутник,
який ми отримали у розгортці.
Висота цього прямокутника дорівнює
твірній. Інша сторона цього прямокутника
дорівнює довжині кола, що лежало
в основі -  2Пі*R.
Обчислюємо площу:
Ель помножити на 2Пі*R
дорівнює: 2Пі*R помножити на Ель.
Твірна співпадає з висотою
циліндра, можна залишити
таку формулу, або записати
2Пі*R*h,
помінявши твірну на висоту
циліндра. Отримали формулу.
Отже, площа поверхні циліндра
дорівнює 2Пі*R*h.
Розглянемо задачу на циліндр.
Задача
У яку посудину вміститься більше рідини:
конічну з висотою 30 см (конічна посудина)
і радіусом основи 10 см, чи
у циліндричну посудину,
в основі якої круг з радіусом 5
см, а висота теж дорівнює 30 см?
Розв’яжему цю задачу.
Для цього знайдемо об’єми цих
стереометричних тіл.
Згадаємо формули для
об’єму циліндра і об’єму конуса.
Об’єм конуса дорівнює: одна третина*
площа основи*висоту (формула на екрані).
Площа основи – це Пі*R в квадраті.
R – мається на увазі радіус основи
цього конуса. Підставляємо величини:
одна третя залишається, Пі залишається,
R конуса дорівнює 10, висота – 30.
Множимо.
10 в квадраті – це 100,
30 скорочується з трійкою.
Разом маємо 1000*Пі. Отже, об’єм конуса
дорівнює 1000*Пі сантиметрів кубічних.
Знайдемо об’єм циліндра. Об’єм циліндра
дорівнює: площа основи на висоту
(в основі в нас круг), отже – Пі*R
циліндра в квадраті.
Але зараз у нас радіус круга в
основі циліндра дорівнює 5 см.
Пі*5 в квадраті*30 (висота та сама).
5 в квадраті – це 25.
Множимо на 30. Маємо 750*Пі.
Отже, об’єм цього циліндра:
750*Пі сантиметрів кубічних.
Бачимо, що об’єм конуса
більший за об’єм циліндра.
Отже, більше рідини
вміститься у конічну посудину.
Ще одна задача.
Ця задача з реального тесту ЗНО.
Маємо лист заліза АВСD.
Оця сторона АD цього
прямокутника дорівнює 50 см.
Цей лист згортають у циліндричну поверхню.
Так само, як ми робили сьогодні на уроці.
Треба обчислити площу
бічної поверхні отриманого
циліндра – оцієї труби,
якщо діаметр основи
цього циліндра дорівнює 20 см.
Пропонується вибрати
відповідь, найближчу до точної.
Отже, намагаємося знайти
площу поверхні цього циліндра.
Оскільки діаметр дорівнює
20, то радіус дорівнює 20
поділити на два – це буде
10. Давайте це запишемо.
Так, радіус дорівнює 10.
І висота цього циліндра
співпадає з оцим відрізком АD. Коли
ми згортаємо лист заліза у циліндр,
ми утворюємо отакий циліндр з висотою 50.
Тоді площа бічної поверхні
цього циліндра дорівнює:
2*Пі*R*h.
в 2*Пі*R підставляємо:
R – це 10, h дорівнює 50.
2*Пі*10*50, множимо і отримуємо
результат -  1000.
Отже, відповідь – 1000*Пі
сантиметрів квадратних.
З’ясуємо до якого числа, із
запропонованих, ця відповідь найближча?
Згадаємо, що Пі наближено дорівнює 3,14.
Множимо це число на 1000.
Маємо, що площа бічної поверхні
наближено дорівнює
3140 сантиметрів квадратних.
Шукаємо найближчу відповідь.
Ось вона – 3150 сантиметрів квадратних,
це відповідь “Б”. Ми розв’язали цю задачу.
Ось ще один приклад циліндру – це шайба.
Взагалі у спорті досить часто
виникають тіла обертання.
Пригадаємо, наприклад, фігуриста, який
дуже швидко обертається
навколо своєї вісі –
утворюється тіло обертання.
Мабуть, можна навести
і інші приклади.
Ну, любий м’яч.
М’яч – це теж тіло обертання.
Да, чудово. Але сьогодні ми продовжуємо
вивчати циліндри і конуси.
Давайте подивимося,
як ви зрозуміли властивості циліндрів.
Питання: чому дорівнює
площа бічної поверхні циліндра?
Давайте спитаємо наших учнів,
і знов три варіанти відповідей.
Варіанти відповідей ви бачите на екрані.
Мені здається – варіант “Б”.
Варіант “Б”? Може …
Я буду бити у той
самий … варіант “В”.
Варіант “В”. От є два варіанти.
На щастя, один з них правильний.
Подивимося який. Правильний варіант “Б”.
Правильний варіант ви бачите на екрані.
2Пі*R– це довжина кола, яке лежить в
основі, а h – це висота циліндра, нагадую.
Так. І давайте повторимо основні
елементи, які ми вивчили на цьому уроці.
Сьогодні ми розглянули
конус і циліндр.
Пригадаємо основні елементи цих
стереометричних фігур.
Конус. Він має висоту
– це ось ця відстань h.
Твірну Ель – це відстань від висоти
конуса до будь-якої точки основи.
І третя важлива характеристика
– це радіус основи R конуса.
Дві величини, які досить
часто вас будуть питати
під час розв’язання задач –
це площа бічної поверхні конуса,
вона дорівнює Пі*R*Ель (R – це радіус
основи, Ель – довжина твірної).
Якщо вам треба знайти
площу повної поверхні конуса,
то до площі бічної поверхні треба додати
площу основи – це круг.
Площа дорівнює Пі*R-квадрат.
І об’єм конуса
обчислюється за формулою:
одна третя Пі*R-квадрат*h.
Пі*R квадрат – це площа основи.
Основа конуса – це круг,
площа круга Пі*R-квадрат*h.
Пригадайте ще раз,
що ця формула відповідає
об’єму будь-якої піраміди.
Об’єм будь-якої піраміди знаходиться за
тою самою формулою
в тому розумінні, що об’єм
піраміди дорівнює
одна третина, площа основи,
знов таки, помножити на h.
Отже, конус – це певне узагальнення
піраміди. Наступна фігура,
яку ми сьогодні розглянули – це
циліндр. Циліндр має висоту h.
Ось це відстань між двома основами.
Верхня і нижня основи – це круги.
Твірна Ель – це лінія, пряма,
от цей відрізок, який з’єднує дві
відповідні точки основ. І довжина
цього відрізка називається твірною.
Твірна – це сам цей відрізок і
його довжина одночасно.
А також – радіус основи R. І знову дві
характеристики циліндра, а саме:
площа бічної поверхні, яка обчислюється
за формулою 2*Пі*R*h.
2*Пі*R*h нагадую – це довжина кола,
що лежить в основі, h - висота.
І об’єм циліндра Пі*R-квадрат*h.
Нагадую, Пі*R-квадрат – це площа
круга, що лежить в основі, h - висота.
Знов таки, формула для об’єму циліндрів
подібна формулі для
об’ємів призм. Об’єм прямих призм,
нагадаю, обчислюється за формулою:
площа основи помножити на висоту.
Тут маємо точно таку саму історію
– об’єм циліндра дорівнює площа
основи помножити на висоту. Ми
вивчили ці два тіла обертання.
Звучить дзвоник, можемо завершити наш
урок. До зустрічі наступного разу!